hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the very important topics that
Seneca is going to approach at multiple
points and from multiple points of view
in on anger book one is the relationship
between the emotion or passion of anger
era right and reason or rationality
razio and I think it can be very very
helpful for readers coming to the work
for the first time without a lot of
background in stoic philosophy to point
out a a distinctive feature of stoic
psychology which is that we our mind or
our soul however you want to think about
it it's not divided into Parts the way
that other philosophies often do so so
there's not like a rational part and
then an irrational emotional part below
it there's the ruling part the ruling
faculty of our soul and that is rational
but it can also be where the emotions
take place and these all you could say
take up the same spot they're they're
roommates rather than neighbors you
could say and he actually says reason
and passion don't have separate and
distinct Dwelling Places but are in fact
the minds transformation to a better
reason or Worse passion condition so you
know when you're being more driven by
Passion your mind itself is in that
condition and it's still the rational
part of you it's just not functioning
rationally as it ought to be as a matter
of fact your reason might be seduced or
subordinated by the ruling passion into
doing some something for it like you're
angry you need to figure out how am I
going to get that bastard right how am I
going to get away with this this crime
that I want to do to them without
getting caught right that's still using
rationality but it's subordinating it to
some sort of impetus or impulse that we
call anger
so the Mind involves both reason and
passion and he will say this is why it's
so important not to let anger get
started or really any other emotion
excessive fear excessive desire and so
he says the mind is not sequestered
keeping a watch for the passions as
things external and apart so that it can
keep them from going farther than they
ought to rather the Mind turns into the
passion when you're feeling anger your
mind is literally anger right it's also
rationality but the anger is what's
running the show so that's a very
important thing to keep in mind he says
how will a reason that has been seized
and overwhelmed by vices resurrect
itself once it has yielded to anger or
how will it free itself from a murky
state in which the admixture of baser
elements predominates and so he says
that we should ask ourselves this
question if we want to put things in
perspective is anger stronger
or weaker than reason and this is going
to vary from situation to situation but
you can say this if anger is actually
stronger than reason
then once you let anger into your your
you know make up your mind your psyche
reason is just going to be subordinated
to it there's really nothing you can do
and reason is not going to be able to
call back the anger or Reason with it or
constrain it or you know make it work
for the benefit of Reason anger is going
to run the show anger is going to
determine the person on the other hand
if it's weaker if anger is weaker than
reason then
reason doesn't actually need anger to
get its job done right so
he says he doesn't have to look for the
weakers party's Aid
or you know what we're dealing with
isn't really anger it's it's something
less than anger he says some people when
they're angry behave consistently and
con control themselves and Seneca says
when when do they actually do that when
anger is already at the vanishing point
and is withdrawing of its own accord not
when it's actually on the boil for then
it's stronger
so you know and then he says but surely
sometimes even in Anger people let off
those who they hate unheard and
untouched and restrain themselves from
doing harm and then Seneca says well you
got something different going on then
right so if you've got a strong passion
of anger and you want to hurt somebody
but you don't hurt them it's not reason
that is calling you back from that it's
another passion
so you know what's an example of this he
says
[Music]
um
when one passion is collided with
another and either fear I don't I don't
want you know I want to hurt that person
but I also don't want to get hurt in
return I don't want to get caught so I'm
not going to do anything about it I'll
you know I'll restrain my anger it's not
reason doing that it's the fear or
desire right you could be like well I
really am angry at my boss but I don't
want to blow up at them because
Christmas bonuses are coming up and I
want to get a raise and I need a good
performance evaluation so I'm not going
to say anything right now well that's
not reason again that's another passion
so that's sort of like substituting one
bad thing for another from the stoic
perspective that's not actually using
reason the way that you ought to to
um you know
do the right thing he says anger has
been still not through reasons favor but
through the passions Wicked treacherous
antaunt which is an understanding right
a standoff you might say
now he also a little bit later
makes some really important contrasts
between
um reason and anger and so let's look at
each of these in turn this is in section
18 of book one he says reason grants
both parties time for a hearing and then
seeks an adjournment for its own sake so
it has time to seek out the truth reason
is not in a hurry it wants to take as
much time as is necessary to arrive at
the right judgment what about anger
anger is in a hurry
and it wants to get things done right
away you know you've all probably had
the experience of being angry and you're
like oh I gotta settle this right now
you know well that's the way that anger
tends to work so that's one really
important contrast what about when it
comes to fairness or Justice you know uh
distinguishing things rightly doing
things proportionately he says that uh
reason wants its judgment to be fair so
even if it's going to be not in my favor
if it's the right way to decide things
well then reason will say okay I you
know maybe give more of this good or
accept more of this harm uh to my myself
you know or to the other person anger he
says wants its judgment here's the key
word to appear fair not to be fair but
to appear fair so it's trying to impose
something that's actually not fair in
place of something that is fair
what about relevance this is another
important thing reason keeps its eye
solely under the matter under
consideration
anger brings in as we say sometimes
everything including the kitchen sink
right as Seneca is going to say anger is
moved by empty vain you know irrelevant
imaginings
and he gives some examples of this two
nonchalant an expression too loud a
voice two free a way of speaking to
refined a way of dress advocacy that's
too insistent popular support all these
rub anger the wrong way so anger is not
just paying attention to the matter at
hand it's paying attention to all sorts
of other things and it very easily then
gets riled up and is ready to go on the
attack what about truth
that reason is motivated by truth truth
is the good for the human being who is
rational right that's what reason is
seeking out he says
um uh here here we go uh
true reason is is looking for what is
actually the case but anger
even if the truth is shoved in its face
it fancies it desires and upholds error
it doesn't want to be refuted so so you
know if the the person who's actually
being rational if they're wrong they're
like yeah show me where I'm wrong and
I'll change my point of view
anger or the person whose mind is angry
right that doesn't do that it takes the
opposite position it doesn't want to be
refuted when it's made a bad beginning
it takes stubbornness to be more
honorable than second thoughts and he
gives a good example of this with this
canaeus piso who is a particularly bad
guy and you know uh there there's a
situation where he should if he was
motivated by Reason by Truth by virtue
he should have done things differently
and said he's motivated by anger and it
actually comes at the detriment of his
own troops who he treats very unfairly
in this case then he goes on Seneca and
he says that anger has this particular
evil trait right it's it's a something
bad uh that he he says what is it it's
unwilling to be controlled literally no
on volt regi right so Reggie means to be
ruled it doesn't want to have anything
telling it what to do and it's
interesting here that Seneca is using
language that has to do with the will so
no one volt it really does not will it
it resists being ruled It Wants to Rule
itself it wants to be in charge reason
doesn't do this reason is willing to
listen to truth reason is willing to
listen to evidence reason is willing to
hear other people's points of view uh
anger no not like that at all he says
that it grows angry at the truth itself
if and there's a big if there
if the truth
contradicts its will and again there's
that that term voluntatam suam anger
itself is a will or has a will it's a
volition
and if truth gets in the way
so much the worse for truth he says he
goes on and says it pursues its intended
victims with shouting and uproar the
whole body's shaking with abuse and
curses added to it reason doesn't do
this reason will you know sometimes take
action like he says should the need
arise it uproots whole households you
know meaning that it kills people but it
does so silently quietly
destroy his families that are a plague
on the Commonwealth it overturns the
very dwellings and the Clans that are
Freedom's enemies and it does all of
this without gnashing its teeth or
tossing its head about or any other
Behavior Unbecoming a judge anger is
interested in doing what it wants to do
regardless of who gets hurt regardless
of how it looks reason is oriented
towards what is necessary what is useful
what is good what is right
so two very different
ways of Behaving and to come back to the
where we started Seneca is saying you're
going to have one or the other of these
you know because you have this part of
yourself the ruling part it can be
rational or it can be angry but it can't
be both at the same time if it is angry
the anger is definitely going to
predominate and the anger is going to
get in the way of reason and behaving
like a rational human being